A SPECIAL LABOR DAY PROGRAM.
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO A SPECIAL EDITION OF
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
YOU PROBABLY DIDN’T SEE IT LIVE,
NOT MANY PEOPLE DID, BUT LAST
MONTH THE FORMER REPUBLICAN
MEMBER OF CONGRESS CALLED SUSAN
SPOKE AT THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
CONVENTION.
IF YOU THOUGHT ABOUT IT, IT WAS
AN ODD MOMENT.
SUSAN IS A VERY NICE PERSON,
ACTUALLY.
PEOPLE WHO KNOW HER LIKE HER.
BUT IT WASN’T REALLY CLEAR WHAT
SHE WAS DOING SPEAKING AT THE
DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION.
MOST DEMOCRATIC VOTERS PROBABLY
HAVE NEVER HEARD OF SUSAN AND
HER WHOLE SPEECH IN JUST A
MOMENT.
WHAT WAS THE POINT OF IT
EXACTLY?
HERE’S THE POINT TOP LOBBYIST
FOR GOOGLE.
SHE WAS A SENIOR EXECUTIVE AT
GOOGLE UNTIL 2018.
SHE WASN’T AT THE DNC TO SPEAK
TO ANYONE WATCHING FROM HOME ON
TV.
SHE WAS SPEAKING TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ITSELF.
HER MESSAGE TO THEM WAS VERY
CLEAR.
SILICON VALLEY IS ON YOUR SIDE.
WE WILL HELP YOU WIN THIS THING.
BY INVITING SUSAN MONTHLY
LYNNARY THEY ALSO SENT A MESSAGE
BACK TO ELECT JOE BIDEN AND YOU
CAN KEEP YOUR MONOPOLIES AND
EXTEND CONTROL OVER AMERICAN
LIFE.
THIS WAS A BARGAIN A LONG TIME
IN THE MAKING.
IMMEDIATELY AFTER DONALD TRUMP
WAS ELECTED IN 2016, EXECUTIVES
AT GOOGLE HELD A COMPANY WIDE
MEETING.
REALLY IT WAS MORE OF A GROUP
THERAPY SESSION.
THE COMPANY’S CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER RUTH PORAT BROKE DOWN IN
TEARS SHE ASKED HOW GOOGLE COULD
QUOTE USE THE GREAT STRENGTH AND
RESOURCES AND REACH WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO ADVANCE REALLY
IMPORTANT VALUES, END QUOTE.
WHAT ARE THOSE VALUES?
THEY ARE NOT YOUR VALUES.
GOOGLE CO-FOUNDER SERGEI BREN
WAS DEVASTATED BY TRUMP’S
VICTORY HE FOUND IT DEEPLY
OFFENSIVE.
WATCH HIM GO FULL ENCOUNTER
GROUP IN FRONT OF HIS EMPLOYEES.
>> MOST PEOPLE HERE ARE PRETTY
UPSET AND PRETTY SAD FOR --
BECAUSE OF THE ELECTION.
AS AN IMMIGRANT AND A REFUGEE, I
CERTAINLY FIND SELECTION DEEPLY
OFFENSIVE.
>> IS THERE ANYTHING POSITIVE
YOU SEE FROM THIS ELECTION
RESULT?
[LAUGHTER]
>> BOY, THAT’S THE REALLY TOUGH
ONE RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: ANOTHER OPPRESSED
BILLIONAIRE.
AT THE SAME MEETING HE SUGGESTED
THAT GOOGLE CHANGE ALGORITHM
VERY CORE OF SEARCH BUSINESS TO
PROMOTE, QUOTE, BETTER QUALITY
OF GOVERNANCE AND
DECISION-MAKING.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY WANT TO
SUBVERT DEMOCRACY AND EVERYONE
IN THE ROOM KNEW EXACTLY WHAT HE
WAS SAYING AND THEY GOT TO WORK
DOING IT.
TWO YEARS LATER VIDEO OF THAT
COMPANY WIDE MEETING LEAKED.
ANY OTHER COMPANY WOULD HAVE
BEEN ASHAMED OF IT.
THE HEAD OF AMERICA’S MOST
POWERFUL CORPORATION CAUGHT ON
CAMERA PLANNING TO MANIPULATING
VOTING IN ELECTION BUT GOOGLE
WAS NOT EMBARRASSED.
THEY DIDN’T STOP EITHER, NO ONE
MADE THEM STOP, SO THEY
CONTINUED.
LAST YEAR A NEW VIDEO EMERGED.
THIS VIDEO SHOWED A WOMAN CALLED
GENERAL WHO WORKS IN THE
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE UNIT AT
GOOGLE CONFESS TO TRYING TO
MANIPULATE THE 2020 ELECTION,
THE ONE UNDERWAY NOW.
SHE SAID, QUOTE:  WE ALL GOT
SCREWED OVER IN 2016 SO WE HAVE
RAPIDLY BEEN LIKE WHAT HAPPENED
THERE AND HOW DO WE PREVENT IT
FROM HAPPENING AGAIN?
ONCE AGAIN, SHE IS SPEAKING
ABOUT THE RESULTS OF A FREE AND
FAIR DEMOCRATIC ELECTION THAT
GOOGLE, THE MOST POWERFUL
COMPANY IN THE WORLD, DIDN’T
LIKE SO THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE
SURE IT NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
IT’S BRAZEN, BUT THEY ARE DOING
IT.
WHY ARE THEY DOING IT?
IMAGINE YOU ARE THEM.
IMAGINE WE ARE BACK IN 2016 AND
YOU ARE A TECH EXECUTIVE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I AREYOU ARE IN YOUR 30’S NOT
IMPRESSIVE BUT HAVE THE RIGHT
CREDENTIALS.
SOMEHOW WORTH BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
DONALD TRUMP WINS THE WHITE
HOUSE RUNNING ON THE MOST
POPULIST REPUBLICAN PLATFORM
SINCE TEDDY ROOSEVELT.
ON THER SO WIDE OPENLY SOCIALIST
CANDIDATES ELECTED TO CONGRESS.
PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF AWFULLY
DARKS LIKE YOU.
HAVE YOU NOT IMPROVED AMERICA.
SOMEONE MIGHT STOCK YOUR STOCK
OPTIONS OR SEIZE YOUR PRIVATE
ISLAND.
WHAT DO YOU DO NEXT?
SILICON VALLEY HAD A FEW IDEAS.
FIRST, THEY BOOSTED DEMOCRATS
WHO ARE ALIGNED WITH WALL STREET
AND MULTI-BILLION-DOLLAR
COMPANIES LIKE THEIRS.
AS LONG AS PEOPLE ARE DISTRACTED
BY IDENTITY POLITICS, AS LONG AS
THEY WERE FIGHTING ABOUT
UNRESOLVABLE ISSUES LIKE RACE
AND JEOPARDY, YOU MIGHT BE ABLE
TO DISTRACT THEM LONG ENOUGH TO
PULL THIS OFF.
YOU WONGT TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT YOU DON’T PAY TAXES IF YOU
ARE BUSY ATTACKING COPS AND
OTHER POWERLESS MEMBERS OF THE
WORKING CLASS.
SO THERE IS A REASONABLE KAMALA
HARRIS AND JOE BIDEN ARE NOW THE
STANDARD BEARERS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
NOT BECAUSE VOTERS LOVED THEM SO
MUCH IT’S BECAUSE THEY ARE
QUIET.
JOE BIDEN HAS TROUBLE
FORMULATING SENTENCES
COHERENTLY.
HE IS NOT A THREAT AFTER 50
YEARS FOR SHILLING FOR
CORPORATION.
NO HAS USED RACE TENSION TO
DIVIDE THIS COUNTRY MORE
EFFECTIVELY THAN KAMALA HARRIS
HAS.
KAMALA HARRIS HAS APPLAUDED THE
RIOTS.
WATCH.
>> I WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT I
KNOW THERE ARE PROTESTS STILL
HAPPENING.
>> YES.
>> IN MAJOR CITIES ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES.
I’M NOT SEEING THE REPORTING ON
IT THAT I HAD FOR THE FIRST FEW
WEEKS.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
BUT THEY ARE NOT GOING TO STOP.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO STOP.
THIS IS A MOVEMENT, I’M TELLING
YOU, THEY’RE NOT GOING TO STOP
BEFORE ELECTION DAY IN NOVEMBER
AND THEY’RE NOT GOING TO STOP
AFTER ELECTION DAY.
AND THAT SHOULD BE -- EVERYONE
SHOULD TAKE NOTE OF THAT ON BOTH
LEVELS.
THIS ISN’T -- THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO LET UP, AND THEY SHOULD NOT.
>> Tucker: THE RIOTERS ARE NOT
GOING TO LET UP AND THEY SHOULD
NOT SAYS KAMALA HARRIS.
RIGHT.
THIS IS THE SAME KAMALA HARRIS
WHO TWEETED THAT MICHAEL BROWN
WAS MURDERED BY COPS IN
FERGUSON, MISSOURI.
HE WASN’T MURDERED.
THAT’S NOT SPECULATION.
BARACK OBAMA’S OWN JUSTIFIABLE
DEPARTMENT CONCLUDED HE WASN’T
MURDERED.
THAT’S A LIE.
BUT HARRIS REPEATED IT ANYWAY
AND HER ALLIES AT TWITTER
ALLOWED HER TO DISSEMINATE THAT
NATIONWIDE.
DIDN’T PULL THAT TWEET DOWN.
SILICON VALLEY IS DOING ALL IT
CAN TO HELP THE BIDEN-HARRIS
TICKET.
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
THIS YEAR, FOR EXAMPLE, LINKEDIN
FOUNDER HOFFMAN AND OTHER
BILLIONAIRES THREW MAJOR
FINANCIAL SUPPORT BEHIND AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED ACRONYM.
IT HAS SET UP BOGUS NEWS SITES
IN SWING STATES TO PORTRAY
DEMOCRATS IN A POSITIVE LIGHT.
OH, KIND OF LIKE THE PROPAGANDA
THEY CLAIMED RUSSIA WAS
PROPAGATING IN THE LAST
ELECTION.
RIGHT.
THIS IS THE PARTY THAT LOVES TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT THE DEATH OF
LOCAL JOURNALISM.
>> BUT THEY ARE FUNDING A
PROPAGANDA NETWORK TO CHANGE
PEOPLE’S OPINIONS BEFORE AN
ELECTION.
AND THE GOAL, OF COURSE, ISN’T
JUST TO MAKE DEMOCRATS LOOK
GOOD.
IT’S TO MAKE YOU TERRIFIED
BECAUSE SCARED POPULATIONS ARE
EASIER TO CONTROL.
THAT’S WHY FACEBOOK BLOCKED A
VIDEO FEATURING THE PRESIDENT
POINTING OUT AN OBVIOUS
SCIENTIFIC TRUTH AND NO
SCIENTIST DISAGREES WITH THIS.
CHILDREN ARE MOSTLY NOT AT RISK
FROM THE EFFECTS OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
ACCORDING TO THE SCIENTIFIC
GENERAL THE VIRUS IS, QUOTE, A
GENERAL MILD DISEASE IN CHILDREN
INCLUDING INFANTS.
FATAL OUTCOMES ARE, QUOTE, RARE.
IF YOU KNEW THAT, YOU MIGHT HAVE
REAL QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
LOCKDOWNS JOE BIDEN AND THE
TEACHER’S UNIONS AND SOME OTHER
INSTITUTIONS IN THIS COUNTRY ARE
PUSHING.
SO YOU CAN’T KNOW IT.
FACEBOOK DECIDED YOU SHOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO SEE THOSE DATA FROM
THE ALAN LANCET.
TWITTER WENT FURTHER AND HAD
27-YEAR-OLD MAJORS LOCK DOWN THE
CAMPAIGN ACCOUNT UNTIL THE
CAMPAIGN DELETED VIDEO
THEMSELVES.
IN OTHER WORDS, KISS THE RING
SAID TWITTER.
WEWE WON’T JUST ERASE THE TWITTE
WE NEED YOU TO BOW PUBLICLY TO
OUR AUTHORITY AND DO IT
YOURSELF.
THIS HAS IMPLICATIONS FAR BEYOND
THE ELECTION.
FAR BEYOND WHO BECOMES PRESIDENT
IN JANUARY.
THIS IS ABOUT HOW MUCH POWER THE
TECH MONOPOLIES WILL HAVE.
IT’S ABOUT HOW MUCH POWER THE
PROFESSIONAL CLASS CONTINUED TO
WE WOULD AS THE MIDDLE CLASS
DIES.
TECHNOLOGY EXECUTIVES IN SAN
FRANCISCO WERE THE PRODUCT OF
THOSE INSTITUTIONS OF LEFT WING
UNIVERSITIES.
THEY HAVE BEEN TRAINED TO
DISLIKE THE COUNTRY THAT MADE
THEIR SUCCESS POSSIBLE AND THEY
VERY MUCH DO.
SO, ANYTHING THEY DO THAT CAN
WEAKEN SOCIAL COHESION IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE THRUST ON OUR
INSTITUTIONS IS OF COURSE
APPEALING THAT INCLUDES PUSHING
MAIL-IN VOTING WHICH EVERYONE
KNOWS VOTER FRAUD.
THAT’S WHY BIG TECH IS PUSHING
THAT AND THAT’S WHY THEY ARE
BACKING RADICAL POLITICIANS AND
DAS LIKE CHESSY BOUDIN IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
PEOPLE LIKE THAT DEGRADE AND
DESTABILIZE OUR COUNTRY.
SILICON VALLEY IS IN FAVOR OF